here we go in
five four three
two
you hear the horn do you hear the call
of battle i've
longed to hear the call of battle once
again
[Applause]
to arms foot soldiers
today i summon thee to the great
battle of
man vs douche
today i shall take on not just one
douche but two douches
uh army of douches an
unforgivable crime has been committed on
us today yesterday actually
said by logan paul he and i'll let the
clip speak for itself
but to have somebody turn off your power
you know while you're trying to
microwave a a tostinos
the little pizza rolls the access to his
power grid
that terrifies me because he has
children children that's like
what what are the cameras facing do you
know what i'm saying like yeah
i hear creepy stories about that stuff
all the time they get like why
couldn't they get like a scum of the
internet
[ __ ] like keemstar
honestly daniel keem he's one of the
biggest
what you just witnessed is a crime
of the most epic proportion now let me
explain to you the situation
roman antwood because he's an
ant compared to me and stature
and clout right
oh it's oh yeah speaking of which this
war is brought to you by honey
no this you know hey they're here for
the whole ride
you come you ride honey rides with us
today
i mean they probably sponsor his podcast
too but hey they're playing both sides
you know what i mean you've got to play
both sides and see who they're the arms
yeah yeah it's fine
exactly um
roman antwood
was being harassed by this hacker doxxer
who was like screwing with his life for
a whole year
and logan says why couldn't he just mess
with
scum of the internet like keemstar
nh3 now let me stop you there ah break
that down a little bit
first of all you clump me in with
keemstar now i don't know if you did
that intentionally or not just to piss
me off
but even i'll be honest with you logan
even i
and you know how i feel about keemstar
would not wish that on keemstar
right even though let's be frank
keemstar has done that to other people
but i wouldn't wish it on i don't wish
it on anybody no and also i don't know
if you've been
paying attention logan but i've i've
been dealing with plenty of [ __ ]
i've been swatted three times by literal
neo-nazis who have
killed people and had to move
so i don't know if that's enough
harassment for you to be satisfied
but that's that his uh friend or
guest the person sitting there also says
they have kids
oh yeah and we do and keemstar does too
right they go well roman antwood has
kids
and logan's like yeah but ethan's kids
don't matter let's send let's send them
all to harass ether
so you know and i was like listen if
you're logan paul
you really like stop short of calling
people scum of the internet because
you have a long and illustrious past
which you're very happy for people to
forget because you've
apparently evolved right i don't think
he's completed still the redemption arc
like let's slow down
he thinks he's he thinks he has i think
he still
holds the actual official title of scum
of the internet that's what i'm saying
like if you're logan paul
right let's just stop let's just stop
short of calling people scum
of the internet because let's be honest
bro that's like uh
i mean that's like adolf hitler accusing
uh like well hold on i'm just making an
analogy like hear me out
i don't okay here let let me rephrase
let's take hitler out of the question i
don't think
let's take hitler out make hitler's out
there's
hitler's god okay that's like charles
manson
being like to the golden state killer
like bro you went a little far
you know what i mean he's like dude you
went a little too far
i like that you're um you're showing off
the word
crime junkies yes i am a crime junkie i
love that [ __ ] i can't get enough of it
okay i mean let's be honest
what i was gonna say strike from the
record is that's like hitler going to
pol pot and being like dude
you went a little too far it's like
excuse me do you know who you are
you know that's like kim jong-un going
up to
vladimir putin and being like dude you
gotta give the people a chance
the the amount of irony like
someone like logan actually got the
official title of scum of the internet
by
like even moms know it you know it's
like it's so amazing world renowned
that that fact is like it's beyond
youtubers it's just like neighbors know
that you know
and and here's what i'm going to take
joy in doing because logan
you know as i said in my tick tock i'm
the king of petty beef
and i don't know if he expected this to
be my reaction but trust me all i needed
was a crumb
and he gave me the whole loaf and now we
got [ __ ] beef
all i needed all i needed was a slice
and he gave me the whole thanksgiving
[ __ ]
pop uh or christmas ham i believe was
what a
christmas ham beef it's not beef though
pot roast uh what's a good beef what's
the dish that you made once with the
marshmallow
and sweet potato that's like a
what is that yams what is the tradition
i'm trying to think of a beef beef
wellington oh a beef wellington
was too much bread and [ __ ] right and
you were making all the bread analogies
i thought maybe
okay all i needed was a slice and you
gave me the whole
loaf of pastrami he gave us a
wagu yeah all i needed is that
is that vaughn's three days past the
expiry date
for 250 and you gave me that a10 wagoon
boy
and now i'm about to sizzle that [ __ ] to
perfection
such a douche and you know oh
is that the horns of battle
i do get triggered my blood is boiling
what we're gonna do today because logan
wants to call me
scum of the internet and i thought well
you know let's take a look at his long
illustrious
career and then we can all determine
collectively who is the scum of the
internet
who he wishes people would harass
maliciously for a year
and instead of roman antwood who by the
way slogan is
smile more now i'm not i don't but by
the way smile more
logan wants me to smile less i think
that the
i he wants there's so much to unpack and
um
someone that says smile more i actually
think maybe we should do an episode
dedicated to that smile more yeah it's
always wrong i love it
but here i don't want to be criticizing
roman in the
yeah exactly so i'm sorry that happened
to you roman i know what it's like to be
harassed by internet people
you know trust me i i know very well us
unlike the scum of the internet we
actually don't wish it on anyone
never i wouldn't with sean keemstar who
as you know is probably my mortal enemy
he's like if i'm uh
[Applause]
[Music]
again i'm searching deep for an analogy
but i don't like
analogies because i feel like you always
kind of go too risky with your analogy
really
you get nervous when i get yeah yo dan
can you hit that soundbite again
whenever you're like it's like
that was that was a b actually maybe hit
that i don't really give a [ __ ] oh
yeah you guys may not know but uh that
was lo when tanner
fox was over at logan's house shooting
videos he said yo i got kovid
and logan said what i don't really give
a [ __ ] ah
that's not scummy oh and by the way he
does this podcast
in person with all these people new
guests every week
no uh precautions taken what would logan
say if i said hey you should take coven
more seriously
i don't really give a [ __ ] right that's
what i would imagine he would say i'd
say this new set looks nice though
it's a little woody yeah but i agree no
i actually i actually agree it does look
pretty good
it's a little woody though don't you
think oh there's so much like let me
let me get a long shot our style i i
definitely i definitely
i definitely can't say [ __ ] about it
other than it's woody it does look
really good though
too bad there's dog [ __ ] on like a pile
of dog [ __ ] right
i preferred the previous one i think the
wood is like
boring like at least there was collar
before i mean what is the wood what are
you in a cabin
i mean what's all the wood you know what
i mean
i'm trying i'm trying to do something
with the wood
what is this the floor you laying on the
floor looks like he's laying on the
floor
got him i'm trying give me a bone here
you
got him sorry
so we are going to i mean there's so
honestly guys and this is a testament to
what an actual scumbag logan paul is
is that there's so much stuff on here
that he's done that i haven't even seen
this all when we were compiling this
list
there's [ __ ] in here that is new to me
and to put that in context
i have followed logan's shenanigans and
the fact that his
his volume of [ __ ] is so
his dossier is so long that there's
still stuff in here that's new to me
is is frankly uh a testament to what a
piece of [ __ ] he is
you know yeah that's right baby okay
all right so we're gonna get to that but
before we do
first of all thank you honey i do want
to start the show off with you know
we have a little few fun things i want
to get to first of all i want to say
shout out to teddy fresh we dropped the
care bears finally
after all long beautiful hard work
um it's up elo thank you
the color blocks are oh no my my pc is
not plugged in
the plug's probably just loose on this
side well it's not
just keep going so um let me show you
real fast
we got i felt uh really proud yesterday
because we've
we worked on this one for super long and
we're happy with how everything came out
and then the launch was pretty smooth
except for some shipping issues
well don't say that you're making it
sound worse it just no
but people get their orders it was just
international orders didn't go through
because we had a problem with our
yeah it's just it's funny how there's
always something
come on logan we're trying to have a
serious conversation i don't really give
a [ __ ]
all right okay i'll get to you
um it was fixed but um other than that
it all worked out and there were
articles and stuff
like forbes high beast what
up rocks oh and what was the other nylon
really cool yeah was it an oprah's o
list
no oprah's oldest it's kind of [ __ ]
it should be you know a lot sold out but
there's actually a lot of cool stuff
still there so i encourage you to go to
teddyfest.com
and you know check it out and just you
know enjoy eel's
beautiful work at the very least so
there's that
i also wanted to thank our members we
love our members
we love our members become a member of
the h3 podcast
becoming a member gets you our all of
our episodes
early the night before right after we
cook them
throw them up so that means that our
normal episode and for enemies
you can watch the night before it goes
up
you also get access to our discord which
is poppin
that's about my spiel on that um
fart gate dan i have something to
confront you about
before we get on to the main yes you dan
now you explain this to me i'm surprised
you didn't see this
this was on the subreddit yes charlie
oh we're having low spoils call in later
too by the way
because we have a lo apparently we have
a beef to settle with him too
it's a friendly beef though i don't
really i i think i i'm we're gonna have
a friendly conversation i like him
it sounds like charlie i mean he's
charlie from always sunny and he
responded to us and he didn't know who
charlie
how does he gone
[Music]
that is so obviously you the fart
no but we'll both sides it's you winding
up the crosstalk
this literally happened last week that's
you going
to clear your throat i don't know it
sounds like you fart no
it's 100 why does it sound so distant
it's literally happened
yes it does why did everyone assume it's
then because it's well i'm the only one
other one here but yeah that's true i
mean it could have been anybody it
sounds like he's over in the corner
going
i feel like you could make a beat from
that which kind of makes me happy
denying it i'm not only denying it i'm
turning i'm reverse carting this that's
totally yeah
we don't believe you the foot soldier
army doesn't believe you
i'm looking at the chat i see people
saying i agree with dan well that was
they're not my
they're not my army anymore i just saw
dan don't speak on something you don't
dan
is right in all caps thank you put mail
on dan's head
what ian sorry dan dan's manipulating
the chat
yeah i just saw dan don't speak on
things you don't know and
put mayo on dan's head oh i'm on my way
to putting mate on your head dude you
better watch the [ __ ]
about that you gotta weigh in that's
kind of always bad still well
i know there was a specific condition
yeah you gotta you gotta break the i
forgot about that
now i'm motivated [ __ ] my health that's
why i'm doing it dude i just want to put
mayo on his head
yeah i'm sorry to be a buzzkill though
100 of your cough i'm sorry huh
i think it's debatable you know shoe
nice
we have a shoe no no what are they they
weren't there they can't recreate the
moment this is like jfk
this is a jfk jfk
you know shoe nice goes against the
family
he's wild man chewie you are a true
agent of chaos he commented on a drama
alert video he said i hate h3h3 bro can
we be friends again
never disrespect you again i will get
dramaal or tattooed to show my loyalty
always remember my fight with epic mail
time started drama alert maybe a pinned
comment
it's awesome i kind of don't see it as
actually going against the family
it seems like an obvious troll comment
to me like he's just goofing on kim star
he's begging for a pen
i mean she was just he's he's an agent
of chaos
well this was this was kind of reflexive
because i mean
he does this thing where he spams our
videos comments with just a bunch of
numbers he'll just start
putting he did it right i warned him he
did it and we banned him don't
do it anymore or we're going to have to
we're going to have to bop you
and we banned him
so i'm willing to to review the band but
like we'll lift it if you just promise
not to do that but
we gotta call in and hear from him and
see he needs to plead his case to us
so if you're there text um zach or a b
or dan and we'll get you on the phone
and you complete your case to us
he sent me a video the other day at like
it arrived in my inbox at like three in
the morning or something
by the time i woke up and looked at it
he had deleted already and i'm pretty
sure it was probably something pretty
mean
oh yeah that's caustic [ __ ] chase's mind
yeah that's
that's classic you know i came across
this song
i love these fundamentals christians who
are just they're the
evangelists evangelists
evangelists
the televangelists are just straight-up
scammers and i love like listen to this
song it's just
i feel like this song says so much to me
this is one of copeland's church by the
way
it is it for sure is uh yeah it's evil
mountain whatever evil even better eagle
mountain oh eagle mountain yeah
oh so this is gonna be the theme song of
the show
[Music]
when i'm watching porn
this is what i'm going to start singing
to ela
i go you look like something
come on man
come on
what could he possibly talk about other
than like farts or semen
or something like that
so zach what i want to do is anytime we
talk to like a e-girl or something or
whatever
or or vin diesel is talking about
something gross
play this
i was like that was weird
this is what i heard when i saw logan
paul like hardcore you know what i don't
know
it's hardcore jesus [ __ ] bro lord
when i saw logan paul call me scum of
the internet i started hearing
something is about the box i tried doing
that in my head
this is my war song bro exposure
[Music]
[Music]
he put on his suit and did his hair and
everything just come out here and be
like something is about the bus
come on come on god do it come on god
bust on me now boy bust on me now
i'd like to see a david guetta remix of
this
shout out to george floyd's family oh
yeah i want it when he drops it and it's
like something
and i really truly believe
that we are changing the world today
shout out to his family
[ __ ] that video is amazing anyway that's
pretty much all i've got so we can
return to the beef that's all we got
yeah that's the show everyone oh my god
well that was just the top of the show
stuff we have plenty to talk about i
mean okay
you guys ready for this a walk down
memory lane
now ela some of this is new to you and
i'm telling you
now my history with logan paul is
obviously a storied one
me and um idubbbz made a video when he
made that silly colorblind video that
went mega viral goofing on him
and he took that very personally so he's
definitely hating me since then
he says that i was quote making fun of
his disability
because um and i mean dude
you can't see red i mean you know what i
mean you can't see red and green like
bro you're
you know what i mean like um it doesn't
matter he played it after that video and
we made fun of it right
he if anything he played it up yeah it's
not like you put on these glasses and
you're
are you wearing the glasses right now i
haven't seen you wear the glasses since
they obviously didn't make that big of a
[ __ ] impact on your life
you know what i mean mother freaking
blueberry duh
okay right and that was the evidence
we're like oh this guy can't see color
how come he knows he's a [ __ ]
blueberry
right anyway i'm not saying he lied
about it but bro it's not like i'm
making fun of like
someone with like disability a
disability you can't see blue and like
green
with peace and love i don't really give
a [ __ ] i mean with peace and love i have
a disability all right
look at me i'm out here like shaking my
hand
i'm not gonna disability shame you but
i'm gatekeeping disabilities
i don't think that's even the point the
point is he played it up
for the video i don't think he would
even argue that
and that was uh raw footage made
for parody you know like that was just
waiting to be made fun of right
so let me walk back my gatekeeping of
this you are very disabled
you are extremely very disabled person
by his own by his own statement you know
what's playing in my head right now
something is about to bust
so logan you know what you know what i
apologize for making fun of your
disability you are
very disabled so much so that i really
should have never made fun of you
because
like at a certain point when somebody's
that disabled
you really shouldn't even make fun of
them because this is not right stop
you know way across the line so i do
apologize for that
now you know
interestingly enough tan no good
[Laughter]
well you know we gotta we gotta
hey something's about the bus
now interestingly just as proof that
he's such a petty [ __ ] right
is that he's held the grudge for so long
and of course there's this famous story
people make fun of me because i say it
so much but
i saw him at a minecraft party not just
house a minecraft party
not just how it was notch's house and he
was standing next to this
bright vintage corvette and i walked
over i'm thinking we were cool because
like you know usually you can say hi to
people and it's all good
so i walk over to logan paul i put out
my hand say hey what's up
and he pulls his hand back like he wants
to hit me yeah he was like
you saw it you were right next to me i
was ready yeah so good i have a witness
and he goes i've i've been dreaming of
what i'd say if
i ever met you like i've been dreaming
you know i was like you're gonna hit me
he's disabled though so
yeah at a minecraft party he's disabled
though so i let it slide
you know stop with that he is he's
disabled
i'm gonna go i'm gonna shut this stream
right now he buy his own admission
i made fun of his disability put the
disability to rest
right now he's colorblind he's disabled
you're bad boy bad boy bad boy what you
gonna do
so anyway oh my god
can people even follow their references
anymore i think you just gotta
i think you just have to stick around
long enough to get the new ones
but it's still it they sound funny on
their own you know right
so he said i'd fantasize about what i'd
say if i've ever met you
and i was like oh really like like so
what did you come up with
and he's like something like that you've
got pubes on your face
and i was like that's good that's good
you definitely should have said that got
him
anyway he didn't want to talk to me he
wouldn't refuse to shake my hand
and he said i have pubes on my face i'm
pretty epic
i do think he's the only one that we
could never like um
get along with right kind of like faster
are you to be frightened
i think you're right like it's we've
always ended up somehow being in contact
with people with
you know even made fun of or criticized
yeah even jake paul
yeah it's always kind of like once you
talk it's all good and
jake has blocked me for the record well
but we did connect back in the day
mm-hmm
but anyway i don't think if you see him
in person he's gonna be like no
he wouldn't i know he wouldn't you know
that's the thing
so jake so logan paul has this uh
distinguished title being the biggest
[ __ ] we've ever made fun of i just
approved the point tana
mongeau is someone we i've made a lot of
fun with and just a few days ago she
tweeted out friendly's podcast is so
good
so even if you're not expecting that
yeah that is everything
like i feel like that literally is
everything
well children people do that and like to
get past
it's just yeah it's like once you do
that too
it's it's only putting us in a bad light
like if we ever made fun of you
we look like douchebags you know but
that's the best approach
especially because he has a disability
you can't make fun of him for that
he's colorblind i'm gonna mute you he's
colorblind
i'm putting you on a on a timeout
okay so anyway shout out to tana mongoo
shout out to her family
and i really believe that tana [ __ ]
anyway i don't know but shout out to our
family
all right so let's you guys go ahead
real just real quick um
there's a ton of people asking what's
going on with zach uh
his power is out at his home yeah it's
been raining in l.a
yeah we've had like a crazy storm and uh
so he's actually he is here on his cell
phone but he can't do the sound bites
today
so everybody's filling in and his stuff
baby and i
are uh covering the sound bites i feel
like i'm without my my
my most important general right now wait
a minute
that camera on your phone looks like a
thousand times better than your normal
yeah what's going on
it does so much better
what camera do you use zach
from the mac tomato
yeah it's built into that into that map
all right
all right he has a massive yeah so
anyway not to get too derailed but god
bless zach i
miss you um
so let's take a walk down memory lane
because let's remember why we're here
logan has dubbed me scum of the internet
and wished that i would be harassed by
trolls and hackers and stuff so let's go
and see
who's going now obviously
this one i can just gloss over because
everybody knows he filmed a dead body
logan paul is like that after he posted
a video
allegedly showing the body of a person
who recently committed suicide
in just 24 hours it was part of a series
from japan he visited an area on the
slopes of mount fuji known as the
suicide
forest they posted the video with the
title we found a dead body in the
japanese suicide forest
during the video paul said i think this
definitely marks a moment in youtube
history
because i'm pretty sure this has never
happened to anyone did you guys
appreciate how psychotic that statement
is
he thought he was like um
trendsetter he's like now now
everybody's gonna be going to the
suicide boards trying to fight uh
suicide suicide foreign force to put in
their vlogs
i wonder what other you know why don't
you just go stand by the golden bridge
and find someone jumping off logan
that'd be cool
you could fish up their body the body
was in the thumbnail right
blurred yeah blurred but in i don't know
if it was in the thumbnail
i don't remember dude was it
i know he showed the body blurred av
says yes
it was i remember no it was like in next
to them no
yeah you put this guy in the thumbnail
oh he did
that uh dead body forest challenge
gone emotional yo by the way shout out
to cam grants
shout out to cam grant's family for
putting this together
the foot soldiers oh my god against
logan paul
oh that's pretty disturbing image
the feet are too big soldiers
today is our day i like the foot tattoo
on your chest that i like the
feet the actual feet are too tall though
it is weird
anyway i set the thumbnail oh so i
probably can't show it but let me just
look oh yeah he showed it
he showed he showed the body in the
thumbnail you can see
the rope dangling
and then the body is blurred and it's
him going
i've made a severe and continuous lapse
in my judgment
right we're not sure that that has ever
ended
that was kind of just a statement of the
state of advance
during the screenshot of the thumbnail
um it's
on trending yeah no they trended it that
was part of the scandal that people were
like
youtube was just like oh logan paul is
family friendly right like every video
of his ghost trending without a doubt
so of course so you know anyway
everybody's familiar enough with that
but it's funny because
it's true with time passes it gets
whitewashed and you think well
that's what happened but it's actually
worse than i remember he put the body in
the thumbnail
i mean that's just oh i never forgot
about that psycho
you could see the the rope yeah and a
blurred body
i don't really give a [ __ ]
i thought you apologized and said that
you cared it was number one trending i
think
for a good amount like i don't know like
half a day or something it was like
number one and that's how i saw it in in
this screenshot it's number 10 trending
and it has 6 million views
so yeah it was a good long amount of
time i remember that
like everybody was relatively okay with
it until
people started to address it and then
like people from outside youtube started
to be like oh my god what
is this because his fans were like yeah
they're like cool
he's he's setting he's the first person
to ever find a suicide body and show it
in a vlog
he's made history and by the way notice
how it's all about
him and not about this poor soul who's
perished in this forest who took his own
life
it's about i've made history yeah this
is a huge day for me
[Music]
it's like whoa or not
not not like i feel so bad i am
i'm gutted my heart is in pieces
no i made history
he's a great adventurer he's a great
discoverer
of human misery okay but that that one's
obvious right
i hate to interrupt the flow here but uh
we're at 30 minutes we should probably
do our oh my goodness knock out our ad
read real quick 30 minutes already
let's think honey and then let's get
right back into the eb
you sure okay here we go we love honey
we love honey
we love honey we really do i
actually really do love honey it's not
bs
you know these days it feels like online
shopping is the only shopping we really
do you want to do like amen after i
finish each line
okay or just like supplement just give
me like a amen
shout out to his family something like
that these days if you and then maybe a
sound bite too maybe
something i don't know i don't know make
it just whatever you got i know you're
working with the yeah something is about
to
oh hit me with that let's play that
music does someone have that i can play
it
[Music]
yes of course they do
[Music]
that's how i feel about honey these days
it feels like online shopping is the
only shopping we really do
that's where today's sponsor honey comes
in it's the free browser extension
that scours the internet for promo codes
and automatically tests them when you're
checking out
honey is your online shopping best
friend
here's how it works you get honey on
your computer
for free and two easy clicks
it's gonna be it's gonna be so much
money they're gonna be singing in
tongues
i got honey on my computer for free two
easy clicks
then when you're checking out out of one
of over 30 000 supported sites
honey pops up and all you have to do is
click apply coupon
wait a few seconds as honey searches for
coupons for that site
if honey finds working codes it'll apply
the best one to your cart
automatically
have you saved any money on honey oh my
god i saved
so much and i i feel like weird saying
it because it almost sounds like a scam
but i really
why would you even put that out there
because
it's like i just feel weird even if it's
too good to be true but i do i start
mining with it all the time
and you add something to cart you click
the honey thing
and then it's like something is about
and then it's like boom you save 200
yeah
no legit we probably we have actually
saved thousands of dollars
it is too good to be true i mean
it feels like it's too big like jesus's
salvation you're like what's the catch
jesus is like no catch bro it's just
love for everybody
yeah don't bite that jesus and i go
something's about to bug
come on what's the hook he's like no
hook i'm jesus that's what i do
come on honey has found it's over 17
million members over
two billion dollars in savings honey
supports all kinds of retailers from
tech
gaming fashion and even food delivery so
it's simple as
pie if you have a computer honey should
be on it
it's free and works with whatever
browser you use you can get honey for
free today
at joinhoney.com wait for it
after dark
wow new code one more time guys let them
know who sent you because
you know foot soldiers assemble this is
important now
join honey dot com slash after dark is
the link in the description down
it sure is oh boy you making the bio
baby you know he's good
click that link bro and download that
[ __ ]
that's join honey.com after dark so they
know we sent you that's
honey thanks for sponsoring today's
episode okay
something is about to buzz hey
something is about to bust stick with me
something is about the bus oh
something's about the bus oh
love doesn't it seems fun though it
seems like they're having fun at least
that's true
it's a hell of a party bruh yeah
nobody parties like a jesus party
and they're just high on jesus
i'm high on jesus
and a lot of um
no what's the one you use for allergies
that gets you all messed up
come on dan you know what sega it's
there's a drug for allergies that gets
people all like high
and speeded out oh sudafed yeah okay i'm
just high on jesus
and a lot of sudafed thank you so anyway
back to logan paul
so um so we all know about the suicide
forest
obviously but do you remember the video
leading up to suicide 4.
the biggest freaking disrespectful
douche piece of [ __ ] ever you could
probably just
go ahead and call him the biggest come
of the internet
thank you the biggest company disrespect
the culture japan is all about the
respect
so i like i think you got to be like he
literally is
addressing that he knows he's being
disrespectful and then doing it i guess
that's what's funny
to the 12 year olds he likes to think
that his fans have evolved
no more 12 year olds i just got to be
careful to not like disrespect the
culture
japan is all about the respect
the dumb americans have arrived look
good
oh don't worry about me i'm just a
vlogger gotta be careful to not like
disrespect the culture
tokyo is a real-life cartoon it's gonna
eat the gopro
what are they doing they're [ __ ] with
the fish yeah
dude that's like beyond
forgiving you're [ __ ] with the koi
fish i mean that's just
so i can't even
see there's details in here that i
actually forget
what did he do
how it is in japan they're all about the
respect we're going to be respectful
logan paul
got smashed shop look they just got
loaves and bread i'll take the whole
thing what's the issue
this one uh it's uh just for a display
oh so i'm gonna be respectful
the game boy color how much
9 500. dude
what what
what he smashed it in the stone maverick
are you forgetting right
i remember he's ago i'm a [ __ ]
maverick hello
dude i cannot believe he's bought
something from dude and smashed it in
the store like
how do you show your face after this
excuse me sir the game seems to be
malfunctioning
it's not so broken though
dude oh this is way worse than i
remember
like looking back he has almost
convinced people that he's reformed and
you start to think maybe you know he
this stuff is so bad
well once they see him in a covered
party it's like oh okay
you're the suicide forest guy right
right right
right
you know it's funny they wouldn't do
that in america yeah
they wouldn't do that in new york they
get their ass beat
but here they go to japan and they're
like because people are like
i guess they're very more reserved so
they like
they feel like they can [ __ ] with people
um
i i have a feeling they wouldn't do this
in new york
all about the respect dude i can't even
i choose you dude
japanese police he really thinks all
these people are just props in his
videos
he literally thinks the entire country
of japan and all of its occupants are a
prop in his
in his video and you just throw a
[ __ ]
pokeball at that yeah let's go back and
by the way that he
kind of is sociopathic like for sure
[Music]
it's coming down i just got to be
careful to not like disrespect the
culture mavericks people who are doing
it differently people who walk on the
street instead of driving in cars hi how
are you
okay do the road to japan hello
mavericks do it differently
how many what it's a prank
[Music]
hey guys you want some fish oh yeah i
forgot about this he's walking around
with raw fish
you just gotta be careful to not like
disrespect the culture
oh my god
they didn't
you know it it only makes sense that all
that douchebaggery culminated in him
going and like he he couldn't be more
i'm in disbelief frankly it's just it's
so [ __ ] up
i mean scum of the internet
you know what i mean it's a rich
accusation but okay
is there really anything to say i mean
i'm kind of speechless
um no not really
yeah okay okay
[Music]
come on other than that this guy called
me the scum of the internet and wished
that hackers and
people would harass me
[Music]
i ain't thought i've never done anything
like that now bye
i ain't never done no fish on a taxi cab
damn
[ __ ] so that anyway dude let's keep
going
you remember when logan paul caused a
ride at vidcon and almost got like all
these little kids
murdered
[Music]
memory lane oh wait that's the
that's the uh the famous frame
everybody wait let me slow it down
everybody um
screencap this because he's like totally
bald
and you know it's i wouldn't usually
make fun of someone's ball but he he
thinks he's so
hot and he's so obnoxious that it's
pretty funny
i'm gonna mute it i don't need to hear
that
something is about to bust
something is about to bust come on say
it with me now
oh is he can i see the number he's
calling in the reflection of his classes
almost something is about to bust
something is about to bust
okay here it is thank you abby
yeah maybe i went back too far too slow
[Laughter]
here it's coming right up i swear to god
oh too slow there so how everybody doing
today everybody's doing okay
god bless thank you very much
here it is okay so he's running
he's running the camera pans up to his
forehead oh
that's the shot now once again i would
never make fun of somebody who's for
just going bald especially someone with
a disability
colorblind i mean he said he's disabled
he's colorblind
but anyway he's bald all right what the
[ __ ]
anyway there's nothing wrong with that
i mean for him we love it
so apparently he like hit apparently he
hit a bunch of money around and then
how's the stampede
and he went running around so they were
told not to do this for
because for safety reasons and so he
went out
running around vidcon
amongst all the the attendees
and caused like this huge stampede
where i believe people did get hurt
and this guy is like has really
everywhere he goes it's all about him
right listen to the music
this is his music oh dude this is his
music
[Music]
they don't care they came in the water
that's what he's saying they're willing
to come in the water to say hi to me
they don't care
yeah guard panicking
he's like what are you doing dude
[Applause]
they're super angry like why would you
do this
and he's like
they're so they're like dude what yeah
take this seriously please
this is dangerous he's gonna organize
yeah they're like this is dangerous
he's dabbing as he's stroke joking
that was one of my favorite moments
let me go back he's choking and dabbing
at the same time
let's not forget about the whole dabbing
thing that's something i forgot about
yeah i'm glad you're talking and dabbing
is great
see that we can't just let all this [ __ ]
slide you know
for someone who's really the scum of the
internet we really have to hold them
accountable for everything they've done
cannot let it we can't forget who this
guy is
so they take him down he's struggling
he's resisting
and then i think he just bolts
they literally just try and then he
bolts
[Applause]
and runs through that confidence ball i
mean he's psychotic
yeah idiot
he's totally destroying the event for
everyone else
by the way like oh it's just not safe
yeah exactly it's just not safe look at
the stampede of people running through
crowds
and the security guards are trying to do
their jobs
yeah well yeah exactly
i thought for sure when i went out there
first off the money who found the money
man i hope brendan got something
second off i thought for sure when i
went out there i'm like i'm six foot two
two hundred pounds solid man
and yo when you guys bond together
you're
freaking strong bro that's what i
preached in my vlogs like as a family
guys i know
and maybe not the time to get cheesy but
together we're killers bro
oh god he has a personality disorder for
sure right
[Music]
i'm so confused so anyway
as you said everything's about him the
dead bodies about him the vidcon is
about him
interestingly though he can't carry his
own podcast
i feel like it's the mike podcast i feel
like mike talks much more than logan but
we'll get to that
we're not ready for that do you remember
when he tased a dead rat
what i'm going to use so i don't know if
i can show this but
this so this is after this i believe i
could be wrong but
or it was before i i think it was after
the suicide forest when he had reformed
and then he tased a dead rat watch this
oh it is after thank you a.b
yeah i thought so so this is after he
was on his best behavior
they find a dead rat and start tasing
its corpse
and putting it on youtube
[Music]
[Applause]
is that alive it moved do you see that
dan
i can't i'm not so here
i want you to see it dan but i don't
want to show them because it's too
graphic can i put it on my
monitor okay so here i'll let you watch
then you comment you comment on this
are we using weapons for this i'm not
going to use my he's got a taser
yeah no rat comes into my house without
getting taped
[Applause]
the girl looks horrified his assistant
and his friend
i think it just spazzed from the
electricity right but yeah it's pretty
disturbing
again
[Music]
again like torturing animals i mean i
know it's dead but like the corpse of
this animal is his play thing
and this is after the suicide forest by
the way after
i've never gotten like all of youtube
demonetized remember when they're like
you are a
threat to the entire platform and so we
have to demonetize you
i mean sure sure you can criticize me
but but that
that you know scum of the internet
something is about to bust anyway so
you know we're making our way down the
list here's a here's an illustrious
history
okay now you this is new to me i knew he
was a
totally disrespectful in japan what i
didn't know
is that he did the same thing in italy
watch
that's jake that's my boss that's
disgusting
so there's a security or i don't know if
he's just a conservative citizen or a
security guard or what
but there's an italian guy being like
you guys cannot do this like this is
this is an important place to us we
respect this place
you know what i mean like you this is
not a playground
he's really concerned he says to logan
as he's taking his clothes off
you can't do this you can't do this and
logan just ignores him
the guy's like please don't do this
and he jumps in the uh
what
he says the police are coming here money
today yo have you called the police
ask them if they could join the location
no so then look there's a boat going
through there
right exactly yeah it's not safe for
anybody so he says to the
to the citizen who was really concerned
begging him you can't do this he says to
him
we lost we lost zero money today yo have
you called the police
ask them if they could join the location
no he says if you if you call the police
ask them if they can join the logang
you're telling me it's illegal no back
me up
okay we should probably leave the
water's disgusting italy i love you
though you smell like [ __ ]
yeah i know bro but that's what it's all
about yo logan
you got one life on this earth bro and
when your brother wants to do some crazy
[ __ ] you best do it with them that's the
maverick
i say it every day push yourself to do
things that no one else is doing and
great things will happen
he really tries to make everything
motivational so cringe
it's like nah dude you are
dysfunctional you you are antisocial
this is antisocial behavior we're doing
things no one is doing
i wonder for [ __ ] reasons yeah
exactly
that's a path i don't recommend people
walk and we saw how it ended
play that soundbite aby if you've got it
that i've repeat made repeated
mistakes lapse of judgment does anyone
have that early from his apology
[Music]
coming right up
yeah that's where walking your own
psychotic path
ends up anyway that one surprised me
there's another
in rome he continued his rampage through
italy
he was flying his drone over like
historic
places well here i'll let her and jake
were both using their drones to fly over
the iconic structure to get some
incredible footage
but while they were flying it logan's
drone went out of range and they
couldn't find it anymore
they used the drone's gps which led them
to members of italy's military
who had taken the drone you guys speak
english uh
we have a drone you know yes that's the
drone i
i mean we call the police because i
don't know
the drone when logan went over to talk
to the officers they explained that they
didn't know what it was so they called
the police
the craziest part about this is that one
of the officers actually recognized
logan from youtube
logan followed their instructions and
talked with the police officers who then
looked into drawing drones in the area
was a weapon and they had to arrest over
his story what's
wrong obviously jake and their crew were
freaking out over this and had no idea
where logan was
logan continued to shoot some footage
with his iphone while he was at the
police station and was eventually able
to leave
without his drone although they kept his
drone logan borrowed some of jake's
footage to show us what he got arrested
for trying to get
yes the coliseum is absolutely the
colosseum but you should probably check
the rules before attempting to get
content for your youtube channel
rolling no this is what i got arrested
for
so they're literally flying their drone
in the coliseum
we are glad that the situation wasn't
too serious and that logan is the thing
is they could crash
clearly they would crash it because they
lost it so
right exactly how does it how does it
stop
how does it look oh wow
well yeah right i mean logan what do you
say were you not concerned that
that you would damage the historic
colosseum all about the respect
i don't expect to be forgiven he doesn't
expect to be forgiven
okay i don't really give a [ __ ] yeah
that's what i thought
um this was a good one by the way this
is one that's often overlooked okay
um he did a prank where he uh
pretended to be executed in front of all
of his fans
what is this
three two one
[Music]
what the freak
ah
[Applause]
these kids aren't even buying it
but obviously such such a bad idea such
a prankster
such a bad idea
zach when you say you get joker brain
you see what we think
yeah that's in my mind no jo he's just
an [ __ ]
he doesn't have drugs joker brain
is it gives you some shoe nice has joker
brain
you know what i mean there's something
redeeming okay and having a joker brain
he doesn't have a joker brain oh yeah
this was one that i guess a lot of
people
were not happy about because kid wait
real quick i've got news actually
bad um
i think ewa actually has joker brain
and i have some photographic evidence
that was just sent in either you have
joker
what's happening we have breaking news
we're being we're cutting in with
breaking news breaking news
so who is gay so who is gay
i don't know we weren't talking about
anything like that okay here we go
oh how do you explain this
wait where was this from i forgot
that's pretty good that was a good gag
like ethan ethan did white face and then
we showed me behind the camera for a
second
and i had it yeah but this looks so
legit
the joker brain oh my goodness you'll
explain this now
that's awesome yeah so this was
regarding the tweet there was a time
when kids were literally doing a tide
pod challenge and people were getting
violently ill it turned into a big
scandal because
i guess people were holding these social
media platforms accountable for letting
people post videos of them having a
eating type of right
so logan paul says swallowing one tide
pod per wee
retweet which i guess people thought was
just kind of
encouraging people to think it's cool to
eat tide pods which is quite cool come
on
man now i go back to perhaps my favorite
part of his illustrious history
um are you ready for do you remember
this one
because i sure did at all hero you
remember hiro
it's burned in my mouth so i remember
his videos more than my childhood
memories it's like
weird that's funny what does that mean i
don't know
but like kind of bizarre
so here he flies out this kid who is his
anyway bro i didn't mean just watch it's
crazy
it's a fact that everyone has a hero
and sometimes when you're just the right
way
you gotta make a dumbass song about it
in fact this is that dumb ass song
and guess what i'm feeling tickled
[Music]
i saw this video saying logan you're my
hero saying i'm the man like i'm some
type of robert de niro i don't know why
though this is this
is nobody told me to track like a gosh
darn tornado just a boy from ohio
following his dreams i'm somebody's hero
wow that's amazing
i'm somebody's hero wow that's amazing
well i guess it gets better believe it
you can do anything
you can go and start a movement look at
martin luther king so he
he literally keyed green screened in
martin luther king into his pool
do you remember that shout out to his
family
do you remember he did this i do he
literally keyed in martin luther king
into his pool
look at this he's saying this kid is
gonna be mark
he says this kid can be like martin
luther king do you know how like
it how demeaning it is to him like
listen to the lyrics
the boy from ohio following his dreams
i'm somebody's hero wow that's amazing
and if you really believe it you can do
anything you can go and start a movement
look at martin luther i don't think
martin luther king
wanted to start a movement you know i
think he did that out of desperation and
need it's not like
i'm a white kid from ohio i could do
anything have you seen the maverick
movement i mean right it's just it is
pretty
it's it's horrific
let's be honest like bro don't use
martin luther king on your swimming pool
of all things right
listen to this lyric after he says you
can be martin luther king now watch this
you can do anything you can go and start
a movement look at martin luther king no
i'm not saying that this little dude is
martin luther king
he goes you could go be martin luther
king but i'm not saying this kid is that
i'm not saying this could go do that he
goes you can do anything
but tone it down kid i wonder if that
was his way to be like
i am he was politically correct he was
trying to cover his face
he was he was literally trying to cover
his base but he actually just insulted
the kid
he could do anything except this
the guy i referenced
he's saying that he's not you see that
and this [ __ ] is crazy i have to keep
going back
look at martin luther king no i'm not
saying that this little dude is martin
luther
king but i'm not saying that he's not
but is he martin luther king
i'm not saying he's not martin luther
king it's up for debate
this kid holding a build-a-bear he's
martin luther king
also why'd he have to do this kid so
dirty why is he gonna put him in this
[ __ ] goofy ass
dude his fit is fire i don't know what
you're talking about oh
it's not a sure thing you don't know it
i don't know now i know for a fact he's
not martin luther king
like i definitely can confirm that right
now right here
[ __ ] crazy you say that this kid
ain't i'm okay
he's not mlk why do you
keep referencing black people by the way
i love that
i love his rhymes i know he's not mlk
bro
that this kid ain't mlk or even kanye
the point is he's a maverick he takes
his own path
he don't listen to the haters who may
point and laugh he stuck his neck out
for me like a full-grown giraffe now
noah it's your turn cause i did the
first half about employees
wait we're getting it twice what
happened no it's doing that crackling
oh [ __ ] we're getting a new computer you
guys by the way crackling
this computer served us well for years
but it's
it's it's hanging in there dan said he
had the blue screen of death when he was
doing tests this morning so
yeah we're we're we're filming on
borrowed time here
so if some [ __ ] goes down that's that's
what it is
okay and here dude
and by the way don't ever [ __ ] with when
i'm listening with logan merchandise
i'm very sorry yeah the shamelessness of
the plugging of the merch i just loved
this song
so much is this on one of your
chill playlists oh yeah
nice hit me up if you ever need advice
yeah right you know he don't answer his
[ __ ] call
good luck reaching logan now
and here dude takes the mavic
merchandise everybody needs someone to
idolize
he is my hero for example this pizza
slice
let's do something cool let go stop some
crimes and hang with all the girls
in paradise say what no
he says hanging with all the girls of
paradise is that a islam is that like a
jihad thing
no sounds like he's saying let's go do
some jihad
stop he says let's go hang out with the
girls in paradise stop
time out time out okay slow it down
slow it down well what else does it mean
the joke didn't work
move on wait what does it mean
i'm not i won't say that again but what
does he mean let's go hang out with
girls
he's lying oh oh okay is empty because
they say
they say that the it's got the paradise
with
the 50 52 it's not 52 how many is this
it's seven oh [ __ ] see even better
i believe i'm so confused right it's a
call to jihad
come on it's funny he's calling all
right let's move on
stop
something cool and hang with all the
girls
in paradise i love how you like let's go
do something cool all right you can go
home now after the video it's like
they didn't do anything cool and they
definitely didn't do jihad as far as i'm
aware
although you could confirm you could
maybe consider this video jihad in its
own right
are you
[Music]
oh
they're harmonizing he's like all right
he's like he goes to the kid he's like
maybe just you just pretend to sing and
we'll
put you in in post
[Music]
now this looks like a memorial like you
passed away okay enough of that time to
start making some sense
back to the hero stuff let's talk future
tense in 13 to 20 years we'll both be
president
so if you talk smack we'll call the
secretary of defense not to mention
we'll balance the federal deficit and
yes i'm aware that my rhymes are super
intelligent it's cause i'm in the zone
i'm an avatar in my element i'm a run
bender here to stay
resident everyone has a hero oh that's
hot
zero people shouldn't have a hero
what song about me twice knowing that's
really nice
fortnite and here dude merchandise
everybody needs someone to idolize my
hero
[Music]
that's a classic and never forget he
green screen martin luther k
martin luth martin luther king jr into a
swimming pool
mlk never forget where is it
this should be the thumbnail for our
podcast
i mean like it's at the very beginning
yeah that's
it too i just i need you guys to here
perfect so this is that this should be
everything this should be my
this kid looks like he shot though but
he tore up that trap come on i'm okay
he just passed it no this this black and
white
martin luther king jr movement
culminated in this moment
he lived and died for the cause so that
he could eventually be green
on the logan paul's pool right
this is surrealism right here bro you
could frame this and
put it in a museum called surrealism
that's true you know what i mean this is
this is wild [ __ ]
and i love how he's turning around
looking into the pool like home little
homies
looking into the depths of the pool
artistic
it's yeah so anyway scum of the internet
yada yada
now here's one where during the time
when he was like plugging his merch
to the point where it was like
it was making everyone feel really icky
like it felt like literal brainwashing
of kids to go buy merch
this is his santa diss track why would
he not deliver maverick merch this year
it's not his merchandise
i don't know bro cause he's santa yeah
santa for sure i got a message for santa
ready
relay this [ __ ] santa i need that clout
god he looks so dumb in his merch
and his little backpack oh hi mr claus
it's me logan paul 22 christmases ain't
heard from you at
all yeah now maybe cause i'm naughty or
maybe because i'm nice
maybe because i met mrs claus yeah this
is the song where you make santa a [ __ ]
by the way
he he [ __ ] mrs claus in the story
sneaking down my chimney i'm breaking in
and mentoring
got no milk and cookies here boy you
ain't ready got a two-ton sleigh yeah we
called it the yeti
and i heard you're from the north but
i'm from ohio fact christmas around the
corner get your merch link in bio
logan paul you use your stock to plug
your merch yeah boy i'm
is
yeah it's like dude just make the song
or
[ __ ] duh got the hoodie got the hat
got that backpack hey i [ __ ] mrs claus
and gave her a magic maverick shirt
people are wondering are we going to
talk about anything else today yes
they are wondering yeah we're going to
talk about more
um there's one more here oh actually
what
yeah but it's fine we began so this is
actually serious this stuff is all kind
of goofy and whatever but
this one's actually quite serious jake
paul listen here
uh a relationship with my brother his
ex-girlfriend
logan paul [ __ ] his head back like
without
without me knowing about it and um
how come you don't want me it was it was
like it was a sexual relationship um
and it was
while we were dating while we were on
while we were oh god
in the back of her head yeah i think
like i know he never disrespected it
logan that
yeah but then she wanted to be stupid
which was just
so dumb dan i'm trying to do i'm trying
to explain what you're saying i just
don't
know if i really buy it i'm loving
zach's angle
go back to how it was zach yeah go
further down
oh my power just turned back on oh
really oh
we got a ceiling fan look at that
we're gonna make it dude so i'm getting
served okay
oh good background ian that's it that's
the minute where the world okay there
you go
that's where you know logan paul ended
uh
racism before david guter whatever his
name is
what do you say his name well david i
think it's david gouda
gouda okay and i think in israel
no it's it's gouda cheese
anyway i you made me call me you may
think i'm scum but i've never [ __ ] my
brother's girlfriend so
that's good there's also this one
there's so much honestly you guys are
over it
i'm almost done i just peed in my
basement
handlebars he made the song stole the
beat from an artist here i'll give you
background as it's going
um
colorado hip-hop band flobots filed a
suit against youtube star logan paul for
copyright infringement
the case focused on no handlebars a song
made by paul did he tweet give the
tweets he made
uh the um that that artist made
it's a it's a direct ripoff he stole it
to beat one i mean it's a famous song
yeah
[Music]
i mean the song is called
it's a direct rip you didn't get the
consent or anything
and the artist was like what the [ __ ]
was he um
was he getting sued for it yeah he got
sued for i don't know what was the yeah
i wonder what happened but i remember
the artist was really pissed like dude
what like he didn't know
he just literally ripped off his song
and it was it's they're not like a huge
super rich band i think they had like a
hit song well that song
they're kind of one hit wonder basically
that and that was so what it's not it's
not like you know
these guys are sitting on a mountain of
gold they're like dude you know what i
mean like
world oh my mom's here
they're here early okay that's fine um
[Music]
dude i'm sorry but i ha there's so much
like remember gp his dad is like a
literal [ __ ]
predator hold on hold on hold on his dad
is a predator bro
remember this one hold on i know here
let me speed it up
okay contestant number one good job
that is it for contest number one
youtube is so disgusting are you ready
okay he's ready number two step on
that's the most disgusting [ __ ]
imaginable god
it's disgusting number two great job
by the way the guy holding certainly
dude his dad literally does a dab before
unknowingly kissing this young girl
three step on
and he gets it good too watch this he's
like not one
not two not three
that girl did not know she was making
out with that okay that concludes our
contest today
of who's the best kisser down to one so
yeah that's his dad
who lives in a van outside the team 10
house his dad is also a kova denier
he this was recently put on instagram
the whole family is called
yeah well yeah exactly the whole family
denies cove it's a run so
exactly so this is
gp gp classic [ __ ] he always he says
here
yo folks what's going on it's gp coming
at you hopefully some of you guys will
look up some of those things i talk
about economic liberty separation of
powers freedom of association
all those things should have been he's
got timothy mcveigh vibes now
she's like out in the middle of nowhere
all [ __ ] bundled up and [ __ ]
i love the libertarian to keep our
businesses
accused of sleeping with an underage
girl oh yeah let's not for oh
right consent is actually his biggest oh
my goodness you're right
see you guys don't crush me this is
important i don't want to miss anything
he in this video he says okay watch this
my hacker taught me a lot please contact
me so i can hire you so he got hacked
and on his you'll notice he's kind of
sweating and he's like pleading to the
hacker like please contact me and hire
me
all right so i can hire you well you may
you may know
what aka you off is what that is so
so he had a video of him sleeping with i
don't know if she's underage but she's
very young girl
okay now watch how he's like trying to
be cool about it
yo what's happening folks keep me coming
at you he is so scared you guys know
that i was hacked by the way this hacker
dude is something else man he is crazy
smart
i learned a lot from him um you know
hacking is actually
an adult way of bullying and i'm like
i just i mean this is their
oh my god this is the tree from which
they're cut
you know what i mean you know
i don't know why the guy does it because
he doesn't get any real recognition for
it
uh he's not really messing up my life
that bad because my life
my i'm just not that important but um
i learned a lot from them i learned
about some ways to prevent hacking all
stuff but dude
anyway the guy put out a video of him
like eating out a young girl
and it's horrific trust me i played the
sound i was playing the sound bites once
on the episode and everyone got
so mad at me because it was so repulsive
that just the sound bite alone got
people tripping out
so yeah so gp is like you know
and then also he's a cover denier hang
on guys
you look don't don't rush me this is
important stuff
okay cover denial runs in the family
here we go
yo folks what's going on it's gp coming
at you hopefully some of you guys will
look up some of those things i talk
about economic liberty separation of
powers freedom of association
all those things should be
allowing us to keep our businesses open
see our loved ones the government is
overstepping their boundaries i said
this before
this mask mandate is bigger than the
masked man the government is always
stripping their boundaries for example
why can't i sleep with a 15 year old
girl i mean
who is the government to step in and
tell me that i can't have sex with any
girl of any age that i want
gp coming at you gp's up come into our
house and tell us we can't spend who's
to say that i can't put it
live in a bus outside my son's house and
have sex with the little girls that he
brings over and grooms for me
i mean who's the government to step in
and say that i can't have sex with a 13
year old
i'm just saying same logic with loved
ones and all this other [ __ ]
everybody should be protesting their
governor i don't care if you're a
republican or democrat
get together and protest your governors
because guess what these mandates are
hurting
everybody anyway
i'm pushing back and i say this
i'd rather speak up and be wrong than be
muffled and be wrong
oh this is a such a great take guys
remember this i'd rather speak up and be
wrong
i'd rather speak up and be wrong yeah
and kill a couple
and you do that frequently by the way so
it's all good being muffled you mean is
referencing like having to wear a mask
yeah logan of course this is the last
one i promise but this is all
culminating too logan paul i haven't
seen him in a week but
this is a video from tanner fox entitled
i tested positive he's calling you tell
logan
on youtube that that is he oh my god
hey man listen i really hate to be
having this call with you right now
i haven't you got kobe 19 how did you
know
uh my mom somehow knew
oh i told jake oh
well uh well i hope you get better go
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] isolate yourself
i am i'm staying at quarantine for the
next 14 days but i know i haven't seen
you in a week i just started showing
symptoms of it today but i just wanted
to call and make sure your whole team
knows
what uh i woke up today and i was
extremely
just exhausted like i just felt really
tired
i don't really give a [ __ ] but thanks
for letting me know no problem man all
right
uh well i hope i hope you're all good i
appreciate you bro
bye later next person i'm gonna call
you gotta love tanner for filming him
without telling him which is [ __ ] up
by the way
but these guys are all just a bunch of
dumbasses like they're just they're all
so dumb they don't realize
what they're doing so that's him off the
script
yeah that's him without the pr i got
kovid
i was hanging out with you which a week
ago which is about the time of
incubation
i think implying like i may have got it
from someone on your team
no or i may have given it to you one or
the other yeah it goes either way
and so logan's paul lozenfell's response
is like okay i'm gonna go see a doctor
i'm gonna tell everybody you're gonna
he said i don't give a [ __ ] and not only
that he continued to do his podcast
yeah bringing guests into his home
that's psychotic i mean that's psychotic
i mean
that's psychotic right
so in summary logan paul
just to go back to the beginning of what
started this all
it's been a long round it's been a long
winded type of way to say this but but
to have somebody turn off your power you
know while you're trying to microwave a
toastinos
the little pizza rolls the access to his
power grid
that terrifies me because he has
children children that's like
what what are the cameras facing do you
know what i'm saying like yeah
i hear creepy stories about that stuff
all the time they get like why couldn't
they get like
a scum of the internet [ __ ] like
keemstar honestly daniel keane
he's one of the big honestly so before
you start wishing bad things on people
you dub
scum of the internet stop dude i thought
you evolved okay
remember who's saying that remember who
you are okay
gp coming at you all right
gpg oh but there is one more thing you
guys
and you know we don't [ __ ] around this
is the real
this is the nuke on this is the nuke
that ends the war
there's no coming back after this
logan paul wiki feet
oh he's got a pretty good rating 4.6
let's take a look what there's a little
blurred toe
i couldn't even get off to that if i
tried
ew
what do you guys think do these look
like five star feet to you look how long
and narrow it is it looks weird
these look like five star feet to you
not to me
now i'm not telling you guys what to do
certainly would never tell
you to go give someone a one star wiki
feed i mean that'd be ridiculous
but what i am saying
is those don't look like five star feet
to me
if i was to go to wiki feed and rate
these feet if i was in a war with this
man a foot war
i would probably give him one star
in fact i'm going to go do that right
now i want to smell feet
it's ela chill why you always gotta say
that
it's just odd ugly feet one star i'm
gonna leave a review too [ __ ] it that's
what zach came back to doing
i love his feet i'm gonna add a comment
oh i'm not logged in
i'd love wouldn't that be awesome if i
start leaving comments
hold on i thought i was logged in we
need a login dan
you got to get me logged in here how
last time you were oh no
it's already going down you know it's
awesome we have a legion of like people
who have
made accounts and are logged in
foot soldiers you know what to do this
war
begins and ends now and he will think
twice before crossing us
so i'm kind of at a loss for words right
now
we'll check you on this later
so um there's a whole other thing we've
got to get into
what's that so the on in our last
episode of podcast
before you do that should we catch up on
any chats or anything like that oh yeah
we haven't done that what how's
everybody doing in the chat anyone want
to express anything
uh well there was a lot of donations
saying let's move on from logan paul
there was yes oh but aside from that
people were donating to say let's move
on yeah well that happens every time
probably a little more than usual this
time but
uh anything else
uh somebody said i made it david great
about to bust vid sent it to a b
ap i need that
so you can find that that sounds good uh
i just want to say i really love you
guys
thank you so much thank you so much um
uh this is my third time asking i really
need to know
why women's sizes at teddy fresh aren't
size inclusive y'all could be killing it
i don't even really know what that means
to be honest we will
get there we just kind of
it's just basically that we've been kind
of testing the waters
so you guys just recently started making
yeah so the silhouettes are new to
us and the demand we don't know how many
people are interested or not
but so far it's been doing great so
we'll continue to expand
and we will definitely make more sizes
it was just
our way of being like caution and
getting into this new
category ian did you see anything
you got anything for us uh
well actually we do kind of need to
throw it to another break
i wanted to jump right right right right
um yeah
okay sure go ahead yeah um
not for you guys it's actually for my
new sponsorship
um what after last episode
you know i saw zack's music and av
stream
and oh i i had to start kind of
diversifying a little bit
so oh jesus reached out to my agent
and uh i you know i got a little ad copy
so i it's just a 60 second
uh you know responsibility i got to do
so just
ian you're taking your own wait you're
taking your own
you're doing your own sponsors on our
show that doesn't seem appropriate to me
you know it's just kind of the nature of
the business and it's just just 60
seconds
at most okay go ahead i'll wait okay
okay so i'll just go ahead and jump
right into that
uh is your stomach
dan can i get a little music is your
stomach feeling a little shallow
[Music]
do you have a bad romance with your
boring lunch
well it's time to just dance because
lady gaga's chromatica oreos
are out now i can't see them i couldn't
see them
they're too chromatic oh that's hot is
that a real product
i just want these cookies to just rain
down on me
all day because a star is born
in the snack aisle that's right
that's right there's a million reasons
to go get these cookies
so act now in a target or walmart
or cvs near you while supplies last
please use offer code salaried employee
not that check i don't know don't use
that so much
go
[Music]
how did you get oreos to sponsor you
you got lady gaga where is my oreo
sponsorship this is outrageous
i got a better agent dude oh those are
hot
do not use salary to employ coupons
salaried employees do not
everyone lady gaga got her own oreos wow
i didn't know
yeah gaga and i have been working on
this for a bit wow you worked with her
on this this is even bigger deal than i
thought
yeah you know see originally she wanted
the cookie to be uh
kind of this kind of this mustardy
color and flavor and i said god no
[Laughter]
will you review the cookie first what
color is that
the cookie's got a green center pink
gross and it says chromatica on the
cookie so
ladies and gentlemen wow
see those donks salary employees that's
all thank you very much
okay now actually do you have donations
to read for us though on a serious
account
and in the future please don't hack our
show and can you please yeah i mean look
we're
we're struggling you know we got bills
to pay i mean
i pay your salary dude you're out here
taking sponsorships
you guys all need to give us tithing i
know where's my tithing the bottom line
here
so do we have um yeah somebody donated
ten dollars and said oops i meant to
donate this to starkiller stream can i
get a remix
can i get a refund yeah that's a double
meme
that's hilarious um
where's the video of the dave guetta
something's about the bus
oh yeah do we got that where's that they
said they sent it to a b
i'm dying to see that looks like they
also sent it to me so
send it out send it here we go
the moment you've all been waiting for
[Music]
yes so shout
[Music]
more base nice try this guy's pretty
popular dave
giudice yeah
yeah cool good for him it's out there
crushing it
um so xxs 10 tantasyon
is there any any any other donations or
comments we should read before we move
on to the next uh segment here
uh lots of little ones uh
people love the head headband ela a
couple
thank you we love the headband uh
somebody said team up with keem to take
down logan
i know i thought about it i was like you
know what
i was like [ __ ] i was like if i'm
petty [ __ ] about this wait till
keemstar sees it he's gonna like
he's gonna like i have a feeling you're
gonna be more petty [ __ ] you think so
that yeah
somebody said i'm on my lunch break
please make it like i purposely
ignore it right keemstar hold up
keepstar what did you think about logan
paul you calling you scum of the
internet
mike is actually a good guy he did
something good yeah
oh actually mo like mike moore now it's
actually his poc mike is really the real
host of the podcast logan just sits
there
[Music]
what were you gonna say then yeah
there's just a donation i'm on my lunch
break
please make ethan watch the video where
this guy turns his dead cat into a drone
no i don't
that's not terrific i don't think i want
to i don't think we can show that
no it anyways that sounds like something
logan paul would do
right right let me play with dead
animals and turn them into robotniks
salvador rodriguez donate five dollars
here's some game stop money thank you
all right okay okay thank you thank you
thank you with peace and love
so in our last episode we talked about
this guy
poyos los is he ready by the way dan
uh no uh we'll send him the link right
now
tv we have a little bit of a
i want to say beef but
when you do like youtube stream [ __ ]
like that like you have to pay your
taxes
right if someone gave me a thousand
bucks that's income
so if if uh if i'm like refunding or i
have to send money back oh then you're
detected
i'm sorry i thought i was watching so
this is him responding to us so i
actually haven't seen this
but this guy went on a kind of a tear
somebody accidentally donated 350
to him during a stream and they said oh
my god
i only meant to donate 350. can you
please return
the the extra money and he went on a
rampage saying like dude no [ __ ] you
sue me whatever yada yada so um
so we were kind of goofing on him and
and and a lot of people were coming to
his defense
saying that you know
people do chargebacks or when you get a
refund you have to pay a fee or i don't
know
maybe he'll explain better when you do
like youtube stream [ __ ] like that like
you have to pay your taxes
right if someone gave me a thousand
bucks that's income
so if
look guys trust me i mean as as tom
selleck says this isn't my first rodeo
i do a lot of business on paypal i've
done a lot of tax let me hear what he
has to say if i'm like refunding or i
have to send money back like some people
are like oh dude just deduct it's just a
loan
and then and then just send him like
three something
like if i'm doing all this bro it's
[ __ ] up the taxes no wait no it's not
literally a refund don't you understand
we process thousands of refunds
it's a wash you you got the income
you then refund it so you deduct it it's
a wash i feel like he convinced a lot of
his audience that
the [ __ ] he's saying is true but it's
not otherwise yeah it would be a problem
for everyone but clearly
you don't think these huge retailers
process trillions of refunds and you're
gonna do like a few and think it's gonna
[ __ ] your taxes up
i went in paypal maybe saying maybe we
should hear him out first maybe
let me watch this let me watch there's a
fee
there's literally a fee when you receive
it there's a fee
when you refund there's a fee if there's
a chargeback there's an even [ __ ]
bigger fee
um uh of etika who used to
stream on youtube r.i.p he used to
stream on youtube and he used to get
donations and he was explaining it like
perfectly like
like oh i feel like all streamers have
dealt with this he was explaining we're
like dude
someone could come into your stream one
day and they could drop a bunch of like
two
three four five dollar donations right
let's say they do like
let's say they do like 10 or 15
like two dollar donations if they try to
charge back yeah
i'm not by the way i'm not talking about
is different though yeah it's not a
refund
yeah i didn't know that they had i feel
like a lot of people are just mixing a
lot of stuff here
and um some of it some of it must be
misinformation like the taxes that
that's just one hundred percent not true
silliness
if you got it it's money yeah it's money
out if you refund it it's
deducted it's a wash it's 100 by the way
it's not complicated it's so easy you
take the amount of money that you've
made
in your paypal which or so you make 300
300 goes out it's a wash you don't
literally have to do anything you don't
even think about it you have a net
gain and that's what you pay taxes on
but i'll let them finish they win that
case they're trying to charge back all
those donations
you have to pay a 20 fee for every
donation
plus refund the original money so you
lose all the money that you got donated
and out of your pocket you paid 20
per transaction and i don't know what
paypal's change
rules i don't know if that's why why why
they're just like no that's not true
like dude this is what we've done i'm
not talking about chargebacks
but i'm sure we get chargebacks so i
don't i i can't speak on this well
yeah i don't know because we don't deal
so much with donations
when we have a chargeback it's in regard
to a purchase
and then it goes into a dispute process
we actually win it a lot because
it depends yeah there's a paper for the
most part we win it sometimes it's like
okay that was actually a problem and can
you google it though i'm just
not that it not that that's definitive
before we go uh much further
on this um he just replied uh he's not
available
oh low spoil what
those spoils hermanos understood he
thought it was yesterday
oh yes bro los poyos hermanos
best chicken in the game brah breaking
my heart over here
breaking my heart let me see i said are
you down to call our show tomorrow
when did you say what did you do
yesterday oh
he said i'm down
okay oh wait maybe i did [ __ ] up it says
are you down the collar show tomorrow
and it says wednesday
oh my god oh i thought you know what
he's right i [ __ ] up oh my god what
jesus
i [ __ ] up i apologize low spoiled [ __ ]
tv
[Music]
on that one get out i goofed up
okay that's my fault we love you we
appreciate you yeah i was looking
forward to the cause
i wanted to bury the hatchet i wanted to
apologize i want to get the bottom of
this
those boyos i apologize with peace and
love
with all sincerity i this is my fault i
own this
this is not okay is he streaming right
now how do you do that uh
i'll check i'm not sure um
with peace and love i [ __ ] up this one
something is about a bust not streaming
right now
well maybe he's got a life he's probably
better
for it's 2pm he should be working maybe
he's got something that he planned
to do on a day he didn't think there was
a podcast on he's doing taxes
he's he's that he's he's at the bank
with pencil and paper being like okay
this donation but this one got refunded
i goofed up
but anyway just just to prove a point
and i know he's not here to debate me
all right but that's a pretty legendary
gopher i [ __ ] up listen
listen i own it with peace and love f's
in the chat yeah
my fault i'm sorry to him by the way i
apologize to him
for giving him that let's skip
it on our charts with peace and love
legendary
apologies apologies
somebody's got a chart right i'm warning
you with peace and love
now the chargeback issue with peace and
love
i'm going i can't comment but i'm sure
you're right that that's a pain in the
ass
i was talking about the donation the guy
donated 350 he just wanted a refund
chargeback is definitely a lot more
um room for scamming for sure
oh we did we got [ __ ]
in the early days of teddy fresh when we
didn't know what we were doing
somebody defrauded us out of tens of
thousands of dollars of [ __ ] it was
crazy
yeah it was the same guy he was buying
credit cards online
and it was all being delivered to the
same address so he would buy credit
cards online
and we didn't have any fraud protection
would have anything because everything
we've done
everything we've done on teddy fresh has
been trialed by fire we didn't know
anything now we know obviously there's
all these fraud
plug-ins and systems and yada yada's now
that we have this so
the amount of fraud we get now is like
negligible
but um
so this guy i guess identified us as
sucker marks didn't know anything
so he would buy a credit card
off the internet buy a ton of product
and then when somebody figured out that
it was stolen
whatever he would go buy a new one and
so he came to our website probably
100 literally hundreds of times but
whenever someone saw the charge
and figured their card is being used
then they would
place a chargeback yeah so we got
chargebacks
like for everything you know so once we
figured this out this was going on for
months
and then there was literally hundreds of
orders
all going to the same address but
different name
and then like the chargeback rate on
these was like 80
and then all the other ones were like
well we know it's fraud so we went back
and refunded all of them
but we took such a major [ __ ] loss
from that
but anyway yeah it happens a lot but my
point was if you're trying to return a
donation all you do is go on paypal and
click refund
it's so easy in fact we did tests just
to prove it because i
was so sure that i was right so dan
donated
ten dollars to my paypal
and all you do is you go there's a
refund button
right issue refund ten dollars ten
dollars
now what this says here is so paypal's
fee was 59 cents
i netted 949 41 from his 10
donation and so paypal knows the fee
they refund
everything so it ends up costing
everybody nothing
and dan gets his ten dollars back and
there's no fee to me
i mean we tested it thank you dan we
tested it several times
we test we tested it once where it was
immediate and it said
something like oh it hasn't been debited
from your card yet so we said maybe
maybe that's why
and then we did it again where it was
about 12 hours of time
and um it did the same thing
so i don't know chargeback's a whole
different issue though i'm not going to
argue with you on that one
all i know is something is about the
best you guys
all just um influence those streamers
just gotta get more familiar with the
taxes
you know they know you do need to file
taxes
who knows he's just saying that because
people don't understand it i don't think
so i think there's a lot of
misinformation
you think so yeah you think this guy
doesn't do is like
have a tax person i don't know we uh we
got a five dollar donation from a user
named small
penis and he said can you refund this
yeah um no because youtube i would
but youtube i can't do it youtube
is different than um a paypal donation
because it goes directly through
paypal's processor so i actually can't
refund it
sorry i'm sorry it actually works great
here
i guess maybe they take 30 because i
don't have to deal with like refunds and
chargebacks that's all youtube's problem
you know what i mean i don't really
understand how it works makes it even
hotter i do love tiny
they're the processor i don't do [ __ ]
they're basically buying something from
youtube
and youtube gives me seventy percent so
there's chargebacks or refunds or
whatever weird [ __ ]
it doesn't even go through a paypal
doesn't anything else
let's just do that so people are saying
he's right what am i wrong about
chargebacks are approved streamer
forfeits the donation amount
and paypal charges them a fee for the
dispute okay that makes sense to me
in chargeback yeah and chargebacks not i
agree with that one
it was never about charge yeah i
literally refunding
yeah i was talking about the whole thing
was about refunding 350. am i missing
something
you know but god bless i mean look i'm
not go i don't think the guy's scamming
by the way he's not a scammer he's just
pissed off i get that yeah
you know i would call that a
false sabotage come into this frame more
something is about to bust so we have to
actually go
it was a shame we have so much more
stuff the new mail just dropped you guys
have heard of the alpha male in the beta
mail
well people have pushed it even further
because apparently the alpha male is the
new beta
because a new male just dropped the
sigma mail
what do you mean the new mail dropped
it's like with a new iphone i'm like a
new man
it's like a new one a whole new type of
man
it's called the sigma male that makes
alphas seem like betas and betas
are just [ __ ] dirt they don't even
exist anymore huh
got it do people
consider themselves betas or obvious i
think that's just an insult right like
nobody's like i'm a beta male
are any of you guys beta males no we
we don't we don't hire a bear we don't
only signals here
not familiar with that terminology i've
never even heard of that [ __ ] you know
anyone in real life who actually used
those terms like innocent joe rogan
joe rogan literally uses that term on
ironically i'm asking them if they
oh in real life uh i
i knew a guy about 10 years ago that
was very into this whole like bro alpha
male 1
it's funny because he worked as a waiter
at a restaurant that i worked at but
he like aspired to uh well i said that
he wanted me he wanted to be a news
anchor he was like going to school to
study journalism or whatever and he
would just like ramble about it to
everybody all the time
the alpha [ __ ] yes and it was just like
it's like why are you
so obsessed with this [ __ ] idiot
that's so not sigma though
you want me to read some some attributes
of a sigma
go ahead you guys ready
sigmas reject the expectations and
operate outside the stereotype of alpha
and beta they live outside the
stratosphere of labels
i bet logan paul is a stigma you think
he's sigma brained yeah
no no no
they're not introverted oh they're you
they they marshal their own drum they
don't think about what it even means to
be introverted they're just their own
being i was one of the things i read
they said introverted is one of the
not true i used to have sex with my body
pillow bro
what is that what is that
was that what is that it's a logan paul
he's just is there context to that or
uh he was doing an interview and he just
uh
used to [ __ ] body pillow yeah nice
i wonder if he put his head on it after
he [ __ ] on it
i wrestled the bear number two sigmas
think material value is insignificant
they have they're driven by passion and
experience and they do not know
feel the need to show off it's all about
transcending
okay sigma males prefer self-management
self-employed i'm checking all these
boxes i think i might be a sigma male 1
sigma's value privacy okay who does well
well
logan paul e we do not seek valid
we now i'm just saying we we do not seek
validation from others or rely on people
sigma vibes say here boys the sigma gang
maybe we should be the sigma gang
we're all sick awful sigma is just
like a beta remastered
that's what i've been saying is this
sounds like a bunch of people
that are betas that don't like being
called beta
sigmas are humble leaders they can be in
positions of power without
lording over anyone
basically describing the best people
it's like they're kind of the best
sigmas have independent pursuits who
defines it like
how does this even come together online
youtubers sigmas control their own
lifestyle
if anyone tries to dictate their life or
restrict their freedom the sigma will
not tolerate it
sounds like timothy mcveigh i think
timothy mcveigh
was a sigma
what would the quartering be he's beta
as far
come on i mean what mean which one of
these
which one of these has a has a bullet
point for peas
and defecates in his basement no it's
kind of like setting your own
rules what then my wife went out for
pizza without me
that one is no there's a beta there's
one there's one
uh you'll see there's like another chart
because there's also like gamma
and omega and delta oh my god they've
got like a whole [ __ ] tier list here
so who's like the most
one of them like gamma i think is the
one that's uh like kind of in cell so
i think he might be
i'm deep undercover
god we just got a seven dollar donation
from uh jeremy from the quartering says
i just peed in my basement
oh
thank you for the update jeremy we
appreciate that
do we just assume that at this point
oh and then the tenth one is sigma's are
the outlier the rarest
form of mail you skip the one where it
says that they're introverts
sigma are confident introverts they
prefer to listen over speaking they're
thoughtful and command a room
if they want but choose not to right
yeah that's some beta [ __ ]
that's right that's some beta
whitewashing right there
sickness sigmas need room to breathe
they can get lost in their interests
and ignore the outside world like
timothy mcveigh
it's all so stupid oh this is so stupid
so stupid
please please don't follow any of this
[ __ ] it's the unabomber
it's all dumb thank you that's right i
agree jeremy
i think as we're all in this stigma
squad
you know yeah for now alpha's in beta's
sigma dick sigma dick [ __ ]
nice one hey alphas and betas sigma dick
well done sir can we get a sigma dick
anyway my parents are here we're handing
off theodore
well they're going to take them for the
weekend because they don't come over for
kovid so i don't see him in a while and
we are
taking a valentine's day weekend
oh nice early really
we're staying home but without theodore
which is code for
just party
i don't know she's ovulating oh
we're gonna so
[Music]
you know the time it is
[Music]
yeah hold the line boys
don't sell gamestop whatever you do
with it boys
this is me all weekend hit me with the
zach
this is me all weekend come on
come on come on
[Music]
is
[Music]
throw yoko in there
[Music]
you just played it
i don't think you can play it at the
same time you can't play them at the
same time what kind of technology we on
what are you using a cassette player
not a good one evidently you can't play
two sounds at once
hey that was fun
anyway about gamestop i didn't really
get to talk about it but hold the
[ __ ] line hold the door the line
hold up these hedge funds [ __ ] robin
hood
[ __ ] all these whiny billionaires
[ __ ]
oh for real because it was down this
morning then i kind of want to hear a
little rant from your
heart like aren't you pissed about what
oh about the hedge fund
robin hood i mean yeah
but i feel not at all surprised i guess
so i mean yeah like i guess it's
upsetting but
this is this is it's all a fixed game
this isn't shocking
shouldn't be shocking to anybody well i
don't know that there's ever been
this level
of just straight up
it's just straight up theft and nepotism
and
what do you call it there has been the
thing is so just right in plain sight i
mean it's outrageous right well the
difference is
there's been a whole explosion of retail
investors basically
small investors using things like
robinhood or
or other apps to do relatively small
investments and everything
and the thing is the whole explosion the
whole business model for those things
is like they're they're harvesting data
like they're
it's not really about investing like
robinhood for example that's how they
make most of their money is selling
people's data to people not by
commissions
sounds like good guys right data horse
i mean it's what everybody does nowadays
right well i saw the ceo like
getting interviewed and he just seems
like such a sleazy [ __ ] yeah
he reminded me so much of shkreli oh
i was like oh man this is a shkreli type
such a douche
but i'll tell you what i'm pledging now
i'm going to invest
a shitload of money in to
gamestop and amc it might not be the
i don't care if i'm full of them that's
what i'm saying i don't
care if i lose the money okay well then
i'm doing it to hold the line
and to [ __ ] i want these hedge funds
yeah they're definitely coming
it's a real thing
[Laughter]
you know yeah only do what you can
afford to lose because there's a very
good chance that this is gonna i'm
planning on losing it all i want these
hedge fund people to go bankrupt
i despise hedge funds they literally add
nothing of value to the economy
they move money around and they hoard
cash they screw over ordinary investors
they do
nothing why do we protect these hedge
funds they are [ __ ]
criminals and to have the ball as this
one guy to come on like nbc
msnbc and start crying because it's
unfair
[ __ ] that's you something else you piece
he goes he goes it's just a bunch of
into these people took their checks from
the government
and now they're just trying to screw
this is just an act of hate against rich
people
we need to pull it up yeah actually let
me send me the video it's in the dock
send me the video link it in discord
okay i love that
i mean that guy by the way yeah he's
he's worth about
three and a half billion dollars oh my
god he
has been uh fined multiple times by the
sec for
instance oh my god he's a criminal
he's a criminal he has the balls to go
on television and say this is just
what you're just trying to hurt rich
people here i think it's this one
oh i'm sorry i didn't actually yeah this
is it you didn't give me the link but
that's it
he must have lost a lot of money he's
done a lot of media hits lately
that are all pretty cringe but this is
the one that kind of went viral
do you know if this guy he must be
losing money on this right
uh i mean not enough that it because i
saw him crying
i literally saw him crying in another
interview he's the [ __ ]
psychopath i don't know it won't play
it's just giving me that old [ __ ]
something is about to nuts
something is about to not
the reason the market is doing what it's
doing is people are sitting at home
getting the checks from the government
okay and this fair share is a [ __ ]
concept
it's just a way of attacking wealthy
people and
you know i think it's inappropriate we
all got to work together and politically
work together by the way first of all
what are you doing for anyone else what
do you mean work together
he's first of all saying they're getting
their checks and they're like
yeah like first of all that's
inappropriate that the government's
giving people they're just
sitting at home getting those checks
yeah those lazy
people who care about kovid the fair
share is [ __ ] what exactly do you
mean that you
he he's insinuating that he is by the
definition of his existence
deserves to be wealthy and other people
deserve to be poor
yeah i believe he was referring in the
longer
version of this clip he's referring to a
comment by biden about
him wanting to raise taxes on rich
people essentially and
having a fair share and um yeah
hey your fair share you [ __ ] well he
takes issue with the concept of fair
share
and you know i just have way less money
than you
you know people always tell me now
you're rich you you oh it's
it's easy to come from a rich person to
[ __ ] say
shut the [ __ ] up my chance my beliefs
haven't changed one bit since i started
making money you know
it's uh i forgot who said it but it's
like when i was poor they told me that i
was
here it is right what is that here it is
that was russell brand smart guy when i
was poor and complained about in
equality they said i was better now that
i'm rich and complain
about inequality they say i'm a
hypocrite i'm beginning to think they
just don't want me talking about
inequality
right yeah
my beliefs have never [ __ ] changed
all right so shout out
yeah i'm gonna hold the line i'm buying
amc and gamestop
and first of all the amc thing is kind
of different than the
gamestop thing but whatever well there's
people shorting amc right
yeah not nearly to this i mean this
gamestop situation is kind of unique
all right i'm all in on stuff there
everyone is saying get dogecoin
dan is making a killing on dogepoint i'm
too late on the dough i don't know about
a killing but yeah i made some money
yesterday
how much dan has been going ballistic
over the dogecoin
it's really not that much money i think
i made like 900 bucks or something oh
that's pretty dude that's a hell of
money i'm done i like it did you exit
the line
uh you know what i did is um i i took
out my original investment because
you're you're good yeah exactly um which
was how much
there's like 250 300 bucks or something
like that
that's that's an awesome day but i mean
like if i put in
10 grand that would be oh yeah 30 grand
right now so yeah but that would mean
you would have tied up ten thousand
dollars for like what five years
doing nothing no i put it in on like
tuesday
oh for real how did you know that
dogecoin was gonna go it was like
wednesday
i i what are you doing buying dogecoin
what the hell i bought it for the meme
like i just threw a couple hundred bucks
at it so there's like
i've got other like cryptos that are
less me me although it's all
[ __ ] you it's all astrology like to be
quite honest with you
love said he made five hundred dollars
yesterday on doug hey there you go
so does anybody when you save 500.
that's not good
actually exiting no is there an exit
strategy here
with doge no i'm not
that's hilarious it seems fun
they're trying to meme it up to a dollar
we'll see isn't it at like four cents
uh it peaked i believe last night at
like eight cents
it's not getting anywhere close to it
yeah i don't think so i'll put i'll put
a hundred thousand in
that's funny money right there that's
just being rich for the meme
yeah that's what that billionaire does
he literally [ __ ]
okay maybe you can tell me i'm trying to
learn always
over and over again what does it mean to
short sell now i understand the concept
of like
you borrow something and the price goes
up and so you have to give it back
at a higher price but how the [ __ ] do
you borrow stocks
how do you you borrow it from the money
market like from
essentially banks and other investment
firms why do they lend you
stocks that doesn't make any sense they
make money by
they it's really complicated i am not an
expert
so i'm sure people are gonna be like dan
doesn't know what [ __ ] he's talking
about and you'll be right
but from what i understand uh
when they make these deals where when
they you know
uh create a contract for short they
there's a there's a small margin that
they include they price in
a little bit of profit for themselves on
that contract and so
they're people do it because they they
can make money off of
selling you the contract for the short
so they get a commission
yeah you can think of it that way yeah
but do they not stand to lose or
gain money based on the stock
fluctuating
uh they generally they hedge
the the short so like they'll buy the
inverse essentially as well
to so that if that happens but
again i i mean it's it's honestly over
my head
it just doesn't matter people act try to
explain it like it's so simple to
understand
i don't understand how you borrow
[ __ ] stocks and then trade it around
it's just
so stupid it's it shouldn't be the truth
is it is stupid yes
it shouldn't exist it just doesn't make
sense i mean it does make
sense it makes sense but should it be
something that people are allowed to do
that's a very different market is meant
very simply to invest in businesses all
this [ __ ] going around with gambling
and speculating and
shorting and all that it's just [ __ ]
ridiculous it's ridiculous yeah no
argument for me i mean i think it's all
it's ridiculous it's just funny money it
took and then you know these hedge funds
manipulate the market all day [ __ ]
long and the minute they lose their ass
they
cry and scream because little [ __ ]
robin hood
[ __ ] you then they got a bunch of one
star reviews on robin and google to
erase it
i'll tell you what right now that's
pretty wild i'm giving i'm giving them a
one star review
in one week i'm going to wait
and google erased them all and they're
back up people are already like no
dan that's not right i told you i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm talking about so
just don't
how is all of this okay it shouldn't be
i mean wall street is out of [ __ ]
control you know
they have been for a long time [ __ ] it
somebody said you don't borrow the stock
it's a contract to sell the stock that's
not no they borrow everybody says they
borrow yeah no they do
well listen we don't know where we're
going i have no idea what you're
all talking about i hope dan is gonna be
okay
you're gonna be okay dan i'll be all
right i'm gonna be all right
i'm investing in okay gaga oreos before
i go
let me just check logan paul's wiki feet
foot soldiers is the war one
down to three point seven pretty good
hmm
yeah we're making problem
[Applause]
assemble now hear me
we have fought the battle but the war is
not won
[Music]
hear me we shall get logan paul to
one star
thank you you're good bro
you're good bro what the [ __ ] is this
all right anything else
oh here's another video this guy crying
this stupid ass
i think um oh this is him i mean i think
it's obvious people can
not only see the emotion on your face
but hear it in your voice oh i feel
sorry
talk about this lee why
i care oh my god
[Applause]
okay that's it shout out to his family
he's crying because he cares he cares
about his
daughter all that you wait i will give
away all my money of where the economy
is
oh my god these people are insufferable
and then these hosts these money hosts
actually take these people seriously
he goes i want to show the emotion on
your face
bro i'm just warning these people man
you better work for the betterment of
society
or your [ __ ] i'm just telling you
with peace and love
the bad things are gonna happen to rich
people eventually
peace to
bring more wealth equality to this
country
because this [ __ ] is unsustainable
people are starving and [ __ ] unable
to pay their rent unable to work
waiting in food bank lines and this
[ __ ] has the balls to go on [ __ ]
television and cry
over billionaires losing money
was it really crying over that i just
said he was crying no he was crying but
was it over that
yes it was over this he was crying he
was
in that particular clip i think he was
crying about
how much he cares about taking care of
people
oh please yeah it's just kind of
crocodile how is that
let me go back that's not what i said
that's what the chiron said underneath
it was about him giving away all
no no no no no that's what all these
dudes always say and yet no
no no wait send that link again bus
i gotta i gotta make sure oh here it is
i got it
something is about to come i think uh
let me go back a little bit let's see
what's going to bring in a wealth tax
i think um i mean i think it's obvious
people can
not only see the emotion on your face
but hear it in your voice
when you talk about this why opposition
to a wealth
he's crying yeah
[Music]
oh people are asking us to watch this
video
oh people are saying it's so okay yeah
this one's pretty crazy
this was the video that shane asked
trisha to erase
people are saying it's actually not even
appropriate for youtube so i'm not going
to show it
but shane when shane started getting
outed for
being a weirdo he immediately tech's
attrition told her to remove this video
and in it he's having the 16 year old
boy twerk
and he's slapping his ass now i haven't
seen it i've only heard it
vin that seriously ben diesel that was
highly inappropriate
that's just outrageous not cool
[Laughter]
that's just it's just insane
anyway i'm not going to watch it because
it sounds really disgusting
so yeah i mean like this video sounds
really bad now if you want to watch
try not to spit out your water i see
what's going on look at how red it looks
now on this camera
not okay look like a [ __ ] tomato
yeah if you want to watch this video
it's there but um
i haven't watched it and i'm not gonna
watch it because it's disgusting i mean
this kid is very
young and shane was slapping his ass
while he was turkey twerking
weird weird out it's disgusting weirdo
i i really want to watch it but
apparently was on youtube for a long
[ __ ] time so who knows but
that's not yeah good good good
good great goal people in chat asking
where eb's at he's here he was
he was uh when zach was gone he was
operating the sound bites so and
yeah today so very impressed
very impressed yeah thank you guys thank
you we made we made it we made it
through
yeah but now that zach's back he can
make
vin diesel sound bites about the
molesters
so thank you very much that wasn't you
it's vin diesel
it was bad let's be real can't blame you
all right well guys what can i say
ethan klein scum of the internet maybe
maybe
somebody super chat yo ela has said
three times now that
the sirens are triggering maybe they
shouldn't be used
oh stop i don't even understand what
that means because she thinks that it's
actually triggering ela the sirens but
it was a fog
it's a little bit but like it's not
really it's it's
it is a little bit but but i'm okay i'm
not like
if i wasn't okay we won't be playing but
hold on they sound that one sounds
different than the one they play in
israel yeah
it's different yeah it just kind of
reminds me that's why it's just a little
bit triggering what else it was like a
horn not a siren
or anyway but thank you for
thank you for your concern thank you you
know tj huffmaster
yeah i'm really not that um
i can think a lot here on the stream
it's fine
she's a tough lady he's a tough lady
something is about
oh man uh love the care bear collab will
there be more
thank you um there will be one restock
because we i mean it did really well and
also a lot of people didn't get to get
their stuff because of the
international whatever so
there will be one race talk and
there there's actually a watch that we
were developing for this release but it
wasn't ready in time
oh the watch is so cool so with the
restock
there will be a watch new product and
undies and underwear for women
women's undies panties
horning said uh the alpha beta thing is
like the fuckboy version of astrology
oh that's so interesting actually you
know i saw a really great comment or
tweet or something about this uh where
somebody pointed out like
these dudes who talk about the alpha
versus beta thing all the time are
the exact same people they get triggered
about uh all the different types of
pronouns out there
oh my god that's really interesting
they're like so angry about all these
different pronouns and yet they spend
all of their time categorizing and
labeling
types of sexuality in men it's really
the same
thing i'll just tell you right now any
guy
[Music]
that ironically refers to himself as an
alpha male
thrown off walk away walk away i'm
telling you
walk away we don't want that
it's not funny alex jones is definitely
an alpha male
actually alex jones is like a
he's a space male he's a gamma ray
male well gamma was one of them gamma
ray male 1 that was like okay
we got to pass off theodore i hope you
guys had a good time today i
am the scum of the internet coming at
you that's right
uh here before you humbly your servant
foot soldiers thank you for being here
hope you guys had
fun because at a
to the good time if you'll excuse me
this weekend's going to be full love
different songs
something here play me off with the
something's about the boss would you
please
all right guys well ela's ovulating
we've got work to do this weekend all
right
guys see you next week
[Music]
something is about to bust